et coucou ou est-ce qu'on est on est
chez tcl on est dans leur show room à
barcelone pas très très loin le mw ce
ils sont bien peu à l'écart peinard ici
comme ça on est bien on est à l'aise on
respire on est chez nous on est plutôt
cool et de quoi est ce qu'on vient
parler aujourd'hui on vient parler
d'innovation alors tcl vous le savez ce
sont des smartphones des produits finis
des téléviseurs on en a déjà parlé mais
c'est également de l'innovation ctcl
display qui vous montrent des
innovations des technologies majeures
pour nous montrer qu est ce qui va
arriver dans le futur haut niveau nos
smartphones alors vous l'avez peut-être
remarqué j'ai perdu ma elle est partie
quelque part à barcelone probablement
dans un club je vais aller la récupérer
ce soir donc voilà soyez tranquilles je
veux être là voir demain pour l'instant
je n'ai pas à moitié à presque peu
importe qu'on va regarder qu'est ce qui
arrive du côté de 7 et celle au niveau
de l'innovation il ya plein de
technologies de smartphones qui explique
je voulais présentait déjà le tcl
chicago lorsqu'on était au cnrs à las
vegas il ya deux ans roule à abbey a dû
pliable dans un sens mais également dans
l'autre et ça en même temps et c'est
plutôt rare c'est d'ailleurs
complètement inédite c'est super
intéressant donc aujourd'hui une vidéo
pour faire un tour complet de
l'innovation au niveau des écrans pour
les smartphones du côté de chez tcl des
concepts qui sont gérés révolutionnaire
passionnant intéressant et qui nous
permet de nous projeter dans le futur
donc on y va on regarde ça c'est parti
[Musique]
donc là en fait on voit qu'on a
différents prototypes attention c'est
pas des produits finis alors pas des
produits finis pas exactement vous voyez
j'ai ma voix est parti mais elle va
revenir je voulais récupérer quelque
part à barcelone je ne sais pas encore
où le chicago je voulais présenter quand
on était au csa vegas à quelques jours
produit fini mais qui ne sera pas
commercialisé sa emmènera d'autres
produits qui arriveront un peu plus tard
et je voulais dit pourquoi parce que si
tu essaies elle devait sortir le chicago
en l'état coûtera un peu trop cher
l'idée c'est de proposer l'innovation
sur des produits comme cela à moindre
coût dont on verra d'autres produits
arriver mais ça on n'en est pas là
ultérieurement d'ailleurs si vous n'avez
pas vu la vidéo sur le tcl chicago je
t'invite à venir la voir je mets un lien
quelque part par là où on va aller jeter
un oeil parce que c'est vraiment
intéressant de voir de quelle manière
tcl est venu intégrer cette techno là on
en reparle plus tard donc ça c'est
vraiment le premier produit le chicago
mais ce que j'avais mais j'avais
vraiment envie lorsque j'étais à vegas
etc en fait lorsque vous passez votre
doigt et bien vous sentez un petit peu
la pliure mais pour autant on la sent
moins je trouve que sur un z flip 3 et
alors on la sent un peu plus que sur le
fine n2o peau mais par contre il ya eu
un vrai boulot là dessus au niveau de la
sensation et lorsqu'on revient se
croyait donc ça c'est plutôt intéressant
tout va se faire ici au niveau de la
charnière regarder on vient gagner en
encombrement c'est vraiment l'idée on
prend un smartphone on le met plus petit
et on a un truc qui est un peu en mode
poudrier vous allez mettre dans votre
poche alors je vous le dis on connaît
déjà un ou plusieurs smartphones qui ont
cette typologie de forme ce form factor
là mais je trouve ça intéressant une
fois de plus de dire ok comment est-ce
que ont bien travaillé d'un point de vue
technologique parce que ça quand un
produit sur le marché on a tendance à se
dire bah c'est un peu tout bas et on l'a
déjà vu mais croyez moi que pour venir
créer des charnières comme ça le travail
au niveau de la r&d il est vraiment
juste énorme déjà pour utiliser ces
technologies nyrs à plier un écran et
l'intégrer ou qu'on arrive sur un
produit qui est complètement joint parce
que si vous regardez le zx3 il se joint
pas là comme ça et si cette manière là
alors après peut-être au niveau de la
charnière d'écran de ce que touche parce
que si on veut pour qu'on ait le moins
de sensations au niveau de la pliure il
faut pas que l'écran se pince davantage
donc il faut une petite courbure interne
qui est un vrai boulot qui est fait au
niveau de la charnière et que je trouve
super intéressant ce qu'on voit ici en
fait ces différentes façons de voir la
technologie et de voir de quelle manière
les écrans qui se plie peuvent être
intégrés dans des produits qui seront
probablement fini un jour ou alors
absolument pas et si le chicago c'est
quoi c'est de se dire de quelle manière
est ce qu'un écran pliable me permet de
gagner de la place à dire je prends mon
smartphone hop je le pli je gagne de la
place jules mettre dans une poche je
mets dedans cela que je mets n'importe
où je viens réduire l'encombrement c'est
vraiment l'idée de ce premier point et
c'est eux j'ai perdu la voix j'ai perdu
la tête en plus tu vas ou pas et c'est
vraiment là dessus que ce typologie de
concept est super intéressant mais on va
aller sur autre chose donc là on vient
réduire l'encombrement on comprend
deuxième point on a ce produit là alors
on va décaler légèrement celui là ce
produit là il est vachement intéressant
pourquoi si on regarde là on a quoi on a
un écran vous avez vu ça vous aura pas
échappé et au dos on a quoi et dont on
n'a pas d'écran ouais ça c'est bien et
en fait cette techno elle est
intéressante pourquoi parce qu'elle
vient répondre à un autre problème alors
même si aujourd'hui c'est pas du produit
fini est en train de taper la balle je
sais pas pourquoi ils ont peut-être des
travaux et construisent elles pas de la
sagrada familia et sinon ils sont en
train de faire les travaux la sagrada
familia à l'esam a donc l'idée en fait
de ce produit c'est quoi c'est de se
dire ok j'ai mon écran je pouvoir
utiliser différentes manières je pouvoir
l'utiliser comme ça et lorsque je pars
me balader que je prends le smartphone
lg met dans la poche et bien je veux pas
risquer de l'abîmer je veux le protéger
donc chez quoi je prends et je plie mon
smartphone comme ça donc là je me
retrouve avec un côté complètement
protégé je n'ai pas d'écran je suis
rassuré ça me va très bien mais pour
autant lorsque je les ai pas forcément
envie d'avoir comme ça donc je peux
faire quoi et bien je peux le prendre et
je peux comme ça le plier et avoir une
partie de mon écran qui va être comme ça
une autre partie de mon écran comme ça
pourquoi pas avoir à près d'un point de
vue logiciel est ce qu'ils sont capables
d'intégrer des choses sur l'arête et
lorsque je veux en grand pour regarder
un film une série ou alors avoir un
notion de productivité et bien je peux
le faire de cette manière là il sait ce
qui va être vraiment vraiment
intéressant c'est de voir comment est-ce
que cet écran qui vient se plier à la
fois comme ça donc ça veut dire que ça
vient de tendre en fait on a un effet où
ça vient un peu le pas dire le bombay
notre cas il est tendu press komax ici
mais pour autant lorsqu'on le met à plat
on sent effectivement l'écran avec la
figure centrale un bien évidemment mais
lorsque je le prends et je l'aimé comme
ça voilà l'impression de le maltraiter
spéciaux qu'on se poser quand les on a
vu arriver les premiers smartphone avec
écran pliable et bien on se disait ok
quelle est la limite est ce que je peux
le clic dans un sens je peux pas le
plier un autre image pour et moi on est
des deux côtés je sais pas ce qu'ils ont
fait est ce que une partie d'écran avec
un petit ressort qui permet d'absorber
cette différence de mouvements d'un côté
l'autre parce que là quand même jeu mais
vachement en tension alors regardez on
est sur un poteau donc lorsque je lâche
il vient comme ça pourquoi parce que
c'est vraiment un prototype si j'étais
vraiment sur un produit fini on n'aurait
pas ce genre de choses on le voit là au
niveau de la charnière voyez
poissonnerie d'avoir le mouvement parce
que c'est pas extrêmement évident depuis
ce matin j'ai les mains qui trouve le
plus plus plus mais pour autant je
trouve ça vachement bien donc la voyez
au tir en fait un mécanique moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya un effet où on
vient tirer davantage et lorsque je le
ramène de l'autre côté et bien on lui
met pas la même contrainte mais pour
autant il ya un truc qui marche alors ça
marche non c'est un proto on y arrive
fonctionnel mais on peut le faire alors
pour autant on peut venir là lui et
c'est vrai qu'ici il a eu un petit souci
pendant le transport donc on peut pas le
voir allumé mais c'est un smartphone qui
s'allument donc on pourrait l'imaginer
allumé et si on regarde au dos qu'est-ce
qui nous ont fait et bien c'est pas un
côté un peu souffler et voyez il a
offert un petit peu mais on voit que
cette partie là vous voyez dans le dos
donc sa vie à absorber effectivement ce
mouvement et lorsque je leur ferme de
l'autre côté regardez il ya un petit
coulissement fallait trier ça vient
petit peu tiré sur le côté lors ya le
côté caoutchouteux qui vient de sommer
mouvement et la charnière dessous et de
l'autre côté ça vient de rentrer
légèrement quoi le concept alors ça
c'est vraiment un concept on n'est pas
du tout sur un produit fini pour
l'instant mais je trouve que l'idée
vraiment intéressant troisième typologie
de produits c'est celui là alors celui
on a de la chance il est allumé hop là
regardez ça c'est le fold est mort et
nous parlerons quesnoy alors les fans
d'iron ckoi et bien on vient gélizé deux
typologies de techno niveau des écrans
flexibles la première c'est l'écran qui
se plie on connaît les écrans qui se
plie on l'a vu au travers de différents
produits qu'on va retrouver ici ou qu'on
trouve d'ailleurs sur le marché
rapportent mais on vous montre autre
chose on vous montre une techno
enroulable l'idée c'est quoi c'est de se
dire j'ai mon smartphone il est pliée ok
je viens l'ouvrir j'ai déjà en premier
niveau d'ouverture et ça m'intéresse pas
ce caviar beaucoup d' usage ça peut être
du visionnage des scieries ça peut être
du partage d'écran ça paye pour de la
productivité mais si j'ai besoin d'un
peu plus d'aller encore un peu plus loin
et bien je peux venir les tendre
davantage et j'ai cette partie qui
s'enroulent alors il ya effectivement ce
bénéfice d'avoir un plus grand écran
mais l'autre bénéfices c'est que autant
ici je vais pouvoir avoir la petite lui
remet ici j'en ai pas parce que je le
roule donc c'est intéressant ça une
façon de dire ok c'est techno comme ça
est ce que ça sortira sur un produit
fini j'en sais rien ce qui est un besoin
pour le marché j'en sais rien mais en
tout cas on est capable de le faire
enfin quand je dis on c'est pas moi
c'était cm donc ça c'est cool on fait
ici on a deux parties on a cette
première partie qui vient se plier avec
l'acs centrale ici normalement son prend
une symétrie parfaite ça on vient de
répliquer ici ça vous donne le format
fermé c'est à dire que vous avez votre
charnière au centre c'est une symétrie
c'est comme un petit bouquin est ce
qu'on va notamment chez samsung sur le z
folle de 3 mais ce que vous voyez ici
sur la partie c'est la partie qui vient
coup il s'est donc cette partie là vient
se coller là ça vous permet lorsqu'il
est fermé bien d'avoir déjà un très bel
écran il ya un très grand écran avec une
grande diagonale mais lorsque vous
ouvrez là vous arrivez quoi 10 pouces ou
à peu près 10 pouces et c'est très très
grand c'est vraiment très très grand
alors il faut imaginer différents usages
de la productivité du titah chauffard
fava chemin une chose avec donc vous
avez votre charnière centrale où on
vient tac on le pli on le faire ça se
situe comme ça ça c'est bien là on loi
dans ce sens à regarder on va le mettre
dans l'autre sens comme ça vous le
verrez assez votre charnière on connaît
un set hippologie de charnière mais
c'est très très bien et ça fonctionne et
on voit notre parti enroulable qu'il a
pour le coup est ouverte donc on va vous
voyez ça bien coulissé saviana ça vient
se rapprocher et après ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on a un petit
retour de l'écran aussi la voyez sur le
côté donc on peut très bien imaginer
même pouvoir avoir cette partie utile là
où on pourra voir de la notification
différentes choses donc ça nous permet
d'avoir une surface beaucoup plus grande
on voit les techno on les comprend donc
là on a une charnière qui se plie déjà
un très très gros travail en en plus une
partie enroulable a donc ça c'est
vraiment un produit qui est assez dingue
le fold and roll je sais pas si on a
réellement besoin d'avoir des tailles
d'écran comme ça mais en tout cas ce
qu'on voit c'est que la course à la
modularité en tout cas est vraiment est
vraiment parti et c'est super super
intéressant autre concept qui est
vachement intéressant c'est de se dire
ok j'aime bien avoir un écran à
l'intérieur et puis on connaît notamment
chez samsung sur le z folle de 3 en un
écran intérieur on a un écran extérieur
alors ça apporte des vrais bénéfices
mais ça apporte aussi une certaine
limite notamment le fait de voir et bien
avoir une batterie pour alimenter écran
extérieur et une batterie pour alimenter
à l'écran intérieur est là qu est ce que
nous a faite et c est les belges ont dit
ok on va faire un seul et même écran
donc là vous avez un écran l'année on ne
s'arrête pas là puisque l'écran
continuer c'est le même écran en fait il
passe sur le côté pour arriver sur le
devant alors c'est assez intéressant
parce que là de ce que l'on dit aucune
différence alors ça apporte de vraies
différences significatives dans pause et
industrialisation du produit parce qu'on
n'a pas besoin de mettre deux batteries
lors il faut une grosse batterie
attention quand on allume tout attention
là ça risque de venir consommer il faut
voir de quelle manière ça sera intégré
voire d'un point de vue software comment
ils vont venir travailler ça c'est
toutefois un produit arriver à être
commercialisée avec cette idée en tout
cas du pillage mais c'est vachement
intéressant parce qu'on voit qu'on vient
plier la dans un premier temps donc ça
c'est déjà un point de vue technologique
vachement intéressant mais on vient
également plié là et alors on peut se
dire ok il est ouvert j'ai souvent
d'écran ça me plaît bien mais lorsqu'il
est fermé ce qui peut aussi être
extrêmement pertinent c'est de se dire
ok là j'ai une partie avec un écran sur
le côté est ce que lorsque mon écran
était un leurre est-ce que je peux venir
d'un point de vue software avoir des
notifications avoir un usage un peu
différent ça vous beaucoup de
possibilités sac intéressant si vous
voulez c'est que ce qu'on voit avec ces
concepts c'est pas tant le fait de se
dire il ya la techno pour la techno on
claironne en fanfare et au monde des
technos et d'entrapercevoir le futur le
champ des possibles est ce qui peut
potentiellement arriver l'avenir vous
avez dans votre écran qui va là et ont
énormément les diagonales elle se
termine alors non elle prend elle va pas
à la honte honte parce que c'est le même
écran et on arrive juste ici alors c'est
vrai qu'on se dit lorsque j'utilise
comme ça à l'écran avant je m'en fous un
peu mais il peut y avoir des choses
intéressantes vous montrent différents
cas des usages par exemple vous voulez
photographier quelqu'un donc vous voyez
et vous voulez que la personne en face
puis se voir et faire son plus beau
sourire et bien on pourrait imaginer
c'est parti là qui pourrait être ouverte
elle pourrait se voir on pourrait
imaginer également lorsque votre
smartphone est fermé et bien je vous le
dit avoir une petite partie avec ici des
notifications même un écran fermer ici
il ya un côté intéressant ça veut pas
dire pour autant c'est aussi pertinent
que un seul et même écran ici puis un
autre écran à l'avant il faudrait voir
comment ça pourrait être intégré mais en
tout cas ce qui est vraiment intéressant
celui auquel j'ai ma capacité d'avoir un
écran pliable avec une charnière
centrale mais pour autant j'ai un gros
travail au niveau de l'ingénierie ou je
prends de cet écran je veux dire un
curieux et gèlera mais là ça vient me
permettre plusieurs choses déjà
effectivement je vous dis qu'on peut
réfléchir en termes d'usagé on a
énormément mais surtout on va venir
gagner au niveau de l'épaisseur parce
qu'aujourd'hui le gros problème des
smartphones est inclinable oubliant que
c'est l'épaisseur pourquoi parce qu'il
faut loger les composants tiers qu'il
faut une batterie d'un côté l'autre en
règle générale vous avez de batteries
une batterie pour l'écran avant de
batteries pour l'écran en interne ça
prend de la place vous allez avoir
double composants graphiques bref on
vient doubler un petit peu l'art du coup
on vient pas doublé on a un seul et même
écran anti cernes va être très grand qui
certes est ce qu'il est très lumineuse
si vous allumez le package complet il va
falloir quand même un gros travail au
niveau de l'autonomie puis suffisamment
de cellules intérieure au niveau de la
batterie mais ce qu'on voit et ce qui
est super pertinents c'est cette
capacité au niveau de la fabrication
parce que s'ils fonctionnaient
l'intention en sasp lien voyez ça bouge
pas si vous regardez la charnière là on
a un truc qui est extrêmement bien fini
on a effectivement un petit écart ici
mais juste qu'on retrouve sur le marché
pour moi il ya rien d'étonnant et ça
fonctionne donc une fois de plus c'est
du proto c'est du concept on est là pour
voir le marché pour essayer de
comprendre ce qui peut arriver à
l'avenir et je trouve ça extrêmement
intéressant donc là je vous montre
quatre concepts aujourd'hui mais il en
existe d'autres notamment chez tcl vous
avez un smartphone qui va dire ce plié
en trois donc il va se plier dans ce
sens là il va se plier dans l'autre sens
alors on risque d'avoir beaucoup
d'épaisseur mais une fois de plus c'est
de se dire qu'est ce qu'on peut faire on
voit qu'on est capable aujourd'hui
devenir un pilier des écrans pourquoi
comment quel usage est ce qu'ils vont se
plier dans un sens alors il ya des
produits finis très clair il roule vois
pas ce qu'ils ont sur le marché
aujourd'hui notamment au niveau du
chicago qui lui n'est pas sur le marché
tcl mais on va le retrouver chez samsung
a implosé depuis 2-3 et chez d'autres
mais cette idée là elle est intéressante
parce qu'on répond à un problème un
produit fini on répond un autre problème
lorsqu'on vient ouvrir et on le voit
effectivement notamment chez des
concurrents mais il ya d'autres
problématiques à d'autres usages à
d'autres façons de venir aborder cette
question du pliable ces questions de
l'an roulable cette question de l'écran
incurvé et c'est ça qui est vachement
intéressant alors ici c'est quoi et si
c'est un tour de force qui est fait par
tcl parce que vous connaissez
probablement tcl au niveau des
téléviseurs on connait tcl au niveau des
smartphones mais il ya aussi l'entité je
dirais tcl display qui eux travaillent
sur des concepts travail bien évidemment
sur les écrans intégrés parce que tu
essaies l'on retrouve pas que des écrans
chez ccm on en retrouve un peu partout
et c'est super intéressant de voir ça
moi j'ai très heureux de pouvoir vous
montrer sa non pas parce que ces
produits devraient pouvoir les trouver
les acheter mais parce qu'on commence à
regarder loin là on est en 2022 mais on
peut commencer à se dire mais qu'est ce
qui va arriver en 2023/2024 2025 comment
est-ce que des industriels prennent à
bras le corps cette problématique des
technologies avec des écrans qui se plie
et ça me plaît beaucoup donc je voulais
vraiment à partager ça avec vous c'est
pas ce que vous en pensez est ce que ça
vous aller parce que ça vous intéresse
que vous voyez vraiment un intérêt déjà
aux smartphones qui se plie est ce que
vous avez acheté un peut-être parce
qu'on a dans le commerce et est ce que
yann c concept là qui vous paraît très
intéressant et comment vous pourrez vous
vous appropriez s'est produit c'est
techno marqué le mois en commentaire
c'est très intéressant c'est passionnant
et puis merci à tesla de m'avoir donné
l'opportunité de venir allaient prendre
l'été c'est parce que normalement ils
sont sous verre on peut pas trop les
toucher il marque et 12 d'autres touch
non peuls et hutch et c'est plutôt
chouette je suis très heureux voilà je
vous embrasse prenez soin de votre
epopée
[Musique]